♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE EVER HAVE BEEN
CONFUSED, CONFOUNDED JOE BIDEN
STILL STUMBLING TOWARDS THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION, UNABLE TO
EVEN EXPLAIN HIS OWN PLAN TO
ADDRESS THE VIRUS OUTBREAK.
THIS IS WORSE EVERY SECOND OF
EVERY DAY, TAKE A LOOK.
>> AND IN ORDER TO AVOID THOSE
VERY HIGH NUMBERS, WE HAVE TO DO
AT LEAST SEVERAL THINGS, ONE, WE
HAVE TO DEPEND ON WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO DO RIGHT
NOW AND FIRST OF ALL, HE HAS TO
TELL -- WAIT UNTIL THE CASES --
BEFORE ANYTHING HAPPENS -- WELL,
THE WHOLE IDEA IS HE’S GOT TO
GET IN PLACE THINGS THAT WE ARE
SHORTAGES OF.
I DID AND ASSIST.
I SUGGESTED THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
PEOPLE IN CHINA AT THE OUTSET OF
THIS EVENT AND WHEN IT ALL
STARTED IN WUHAN PROVINCE.
>> Sean: ANY OF YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT?
HEARS REACTION, PLUS ESTATE,
DEMOCRATS KEEP HEARING THE
CHATTER, THE CHITTER CHATTER.
THAT GOT TO DUMP BIDEN FOR
NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO.
WAIT UNTIL I TELL AMERICA ABOUT
HIS RECORD.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE JEOPARDY
CHIEF OF STAFF KARL ROVE.
CARL, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I GUESS IF JOE BIDEN SAYS I’M
OUT THAN THEY ARE GOING TO
BYPASS BERNIE AND GO TO CUOMO?
NEW YORK HYPER, SUPER LIBERAL
THAT LETS OUT CRIMINALS AND HAS
A SANCTUARY STATE, THE WHOLE
BIT?
>> NO, NO.
LOOK, THE ONLY WAY -- THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE IS NOT GOING
TO BE JOE BIDEN’S IF THERE’S A
CATASTROPHE INVOLVING BIDEN.
AND EVEN THEN THEY ARE UNLIKELY
TO TURN TO SOMEBODY OUTSIDE THE
CREW THAT HAS RUN FOR THE
NOMINATION.
SO LOOK.
CUOMO WAS VERY SHARP AND VERY
CLEAR AND PRECISE WITH HIS
BROTHER, NO WAY IN HECK IS HE
GOING TO BE -- RUN FOR PRESIDENT
OR WANT TO BE CONSIDERED FOR
PRESIDENT.
I THOUGHT HE WAS VERY CLEAR ON
THAT AND THIS IS A FANTASY IN
THE FLIRTATION THAT PEOPLE HAVE
WITH REPLACING JOE BIDEN WITH
ANDREW CUOMO IS INDICATIVE OF A
BIGGER PROBLEM THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE.
YOU SAW IT IN THE ABC
"WASHINGTON POST" FALL.
IT CAME OUT ON MARCH 25TH.
IT SHOWED BIDEN AND LEE 49-47,
DOWN FROM A MONTH EARLIER WHERE
HE LED 52-45.
BUT THE INTERESTING THING IS
THIS.
OF THE BIDEN SUPPORTERS, ONLY
24% SAY THEY ARE VERY
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THEIR CHOICE.
THAT MEANS THAT ABOUT 12% OF THE
ELECTORATE IS VERY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT BIDEN.
AMONG THE TRANSPORTERS, 53% SAY
THEY ARE VERY ENTHUSED.
THAT’S ABOUT 26% OF THE
ELECTORATE.
SO BETTER THAN BY MARGIN OF 2:1,
THE ELECTORATE IS MORE
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT TRUMP THAN IT
IS ABOUT BIDEN.
THAT’S A REAL PROBLEM IF YOU’RE
A DEMOCRAT.
>> Sean: I THINK EVERY
DEMOCRAT NEEDS TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
THE DONALD TRUMP TO THE RIGHT
THING WITH THE TRAVEL BAN.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS IN
WASHINGTON WILL HAVE TO ANSWER.
WAS IT ATROCIOUS WHAT THEY DID
HOLDING UP FUNDING FOR HOSPITALS
AND WORKERS IN SMALL AND BIG
BUSINESSES SO THEY COULD FUND
THE KENNEDY CENTER AND THE
NATIONAL ENDOWMENT FOR THE ARTS?
DO THEY NOW SUPPORT OPEN BORDERS
AND SANCTUARY CITIES AND FREE
HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS?
THESE ARE NOT FRONT AND CENTER.
>> YEAH.
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT THE RELIEF
BILL.
I MEAN, REALLY, DO YOU THINK
SAME-DAY VOTER REGISTRATION WAS
A CRITICAL ELEMENT IN FIGHTING
THE CORONAVIRUS?
DO THINK THAT $100 MILLION FOR
NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO WAS
CRITICAL?
THEY WANTED $35 MILLION FOR THE
KENNEDY CENTER.
IF IT ULTIMATELY GIVE THEM 25,
AND YOU KNOW THE KENNEDY CENTER
PROCEEDED TO DO?
FIRE EVERY MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL STATE -- AND SAY WE
CAN’T AFFORD TO PAY YOU.
IT WAS MEANT TO KEEP THEM
ABOARD.
>> Sean: FIGHTING FOR THAT
GARBAGE, THEY BASICALLY TOOK
THEIR MIDDLE FINGER AND SHOVED
IT IN THE FACE OF EVERY AMERICAN
WORKER, EVERY SMALL AND BIG
BUSINESS AND EVERY HOSPITAL
WORKER THAT NEEDED THAT MONEY